Huh?
I wasn't sitting here for seven minutes, was I?
At the open excrement?
The chat is frozen.
Baby?
No!
What was I doing?
I think I completely...
I think I could...
No.
Chow is frozen.
That's not me.
That's a YouTube being stinky again.
It'll occasionally freeze, I think.
YouTube is being so funky.
No, there's no way.
Did I just space out for like five minutes?
Wait, I just I just looked up at the timer and it says it
said seven minutes that I was live.
There's no way.
But then also OBS is the same thing that I just...
What was I doing?
Welcome back.
What do you mean welcome back?
Is it like that I'm home or that I...
Or that I snap back to reality?
I don't know.
What happened to me?
Both.
Boy, boy, boy, boy.
I'm so confused right now.
I keep fighting the jet hag in real time.
Thank you guys for the gift of membership.
So welcome back to membership, everybody.
Thank you.
Welcome home.
Glad you snapped back to reality for us.
I truly, it felt like one minute to me.
Oh, this is, that's crazy.
actually crazy, you see?
That's actually, that's like a horror movie, I think, right
there.
I'm kind of, I'm...
Am I okay?
Oh.
Here, let me put on some VGM before I start sing-sang.
You blinked in minutes past.
Yeah, that's how I feel.
I don't think that's a question for you.
You fully zoned out for seven minutes.
That's kind of crazy.
It's been a wacky 24 hours.
48?
48 hours for me.
Mickey is back.
The meds have finally worn off.
That reminds me.
I watched on the plane.
I watched a movie called that I would always felt like I
wanted to watch.
Shutter Island.
Have you guys seen that movie?
For those who haven't seen it, I don't want to spoil it.
But that's what you're...
That's what you're...
Super Tower, Miami now.
That's a good movie, no?
I mean, are any of us okay?
Also, this backdrop is so cute.
Isn't it?
Thanks!
Storm's coming.
Yeah, it was a good movie.
If you haven't seen it, I recommend it.
And maybe you saw it a long time ago.
Can you spoil a 15-year-old movie?
That's so true.
I didn't realize it was Martin Scorsese, though.
I was like, whoa.
When that came up, I was like, whoa.
This probably will be good then.
I just, I watched it kind of on a whim because I was like, I
remember.
I remember this movie.
But I think back then, Mama Minto, it was like too scary.
Do not watch.
So, you saw it when it released in theaters.
Wow.
Really love the movie that leaves me thinking that the end
of Shutter Island is one of those.
At what point in your flight did you fall in the toilet?
Such a rude question.
You know what?
It was even worse my answer.
It was like right after we took...
I
was sitting...
For so long.
I thought they were joking.
No!
It was a hell of a...
scenario yeah health scenario is a great way to put it oh
goodness gracious hi guys i'm back i went to japan again and
you're probably like what the heck am i doing what's wrong
with you why do you keep going back to japan okay but i have
a good reason i agree brazenbolt okay there
was a spell okay it was like a it was like such a chance so
there was an idol and she she was doing a celebration live
and she is friends with two of my Oshi who have both
graduated actually not even just graduated they've retired
from being idols right and they don't know each other at all
my two Oshi they were from two completely separate groups
but she just happens to be friends with both of them and for
this celebration invited both of them and she and so one of
my oh she I hadn't seen her in over a year she graduated or
retired last year yeah last year and so I got to see her
again and I got to tell her how much I missed her and she
told me how much she missed me so and i got to see them
literally standing next to each other which i had never seen
them stand next to each other before which was like a crazy
crazy it was crazy but it was an extremely good show i was
so happy i went because they performed a lot of songs that i
really love because the girl that was doing the celebration
live has been in a lot of idol groups that i liked um so
helping replenishments gotcha funds from the trip thank you
can you confirm they aren't the same person now i i could
confirm before they are two completely entirely different
souls beings but oh it was so good so honestly even though i
was exhausted because i was like okay here i go back on the
flight back to japan It was worth it.
It was worth it just so that I could see them standing in
the same room together.
It was a lot of fun.
24 months of Vintoteca!
If multiple oceans of mine were put on a stage, I'd
definitely be the...
Oh, wait.
See you in California.
Yeah!
Remix.
California.
Wait, or is that Canada?
Canada or California?
Maybe that's why I stuttered because I couldn't tell.
Canada, can...
Canade dephoria.
Dephoria.
It applies to both, right?
I guess that's true.
That's true.
Say it is both California and Canada.
Yes!
There, you know, there is a, there is an airport in
California that is, oh,
hold on.
Called, it is Ontario, California.
So when you get the ticket, the airplane ticket to Ontario,
California, it says Ontario CA.
And every time I'm like, huh?
I'm sweating I'm like It's so confusing It's so confusing
The missing friend link between two Oshis and Minto Jumping
in the middle Yeah yeah yeah Happy Minky Enjoyed some Minky
time Excited for the off-cut concert Thank you While I was
gone I went to an idol show Oh Almost every day.
I went to...
Wait, what is that?
Sorry, something was on my desk.
I went to 1, 2, 3...
4, 5, 6.
Yippee!
I almost went to 7, but I was like, you know what?
I should rest today.
But it was so fun!
And I got to see it on my ashes.
And I was like...
No!
On the seventh day she rested.
I was still embarrassed when we agreed with you and we've
gone.
I remember you suggested that.
The meaning would be funny for a VTuber.
You should check out Love, Love, Love instead.
Like, should I...
Ken.
I remember you suggesting that.
Roku-nana.
I think the kids in Japan don't say Roku-nana.
I think they actually say 6-7.
I think they go 6-7.
6-7.
I don't think they say Roku-nana.
That's even worse.
I agree.
I agree as I think it's worse.
But I don't know, I didn't hear it.
I only saw someone tweet being like, Why am I hearing the
children outside scream 6, 6 or 7?
Starting English learning early.
I can count to 6 or 7, you guys.
1, 2, 3, 4.
Six or seven was the first thing that came up in my JP
predictive text.
That's a you problem, baby.
Like I'm only doing 3D printing, you.
Yay!
Six, seven idle shows?
Yeah.
So, it was a...
It was mostly just all I did.
I did do a little bit of stuff for a secret project of mine.
That you guys will see in a couple months, maybe.
And what else did I do?
Oh my gosh.
Guys!
I...
Um...
What was I gonna say actually?
Sorry, I am so tired.
I got home yesterday!
And then I was like...
I got saved!
For my taxes!
Someone was just like, I got you.
Let me help.
And I was like, okay, I assume that probably I'll like file
an extension.
Sorry for real world talk, but I was like, I think I'm
assuming we'll file extension and then work on upcoming days
or whatever, whatever.
And they were like, no.
We're doing this tonight.
And I was like, huh?
Huh?
Because of my previous tax person.
Stopped responding to me.
And they were like, no, we're doing it tonight.
And I was like, okay.
So I was up until 2 in the morning doing my taxes.
And then I woke up and finished them.
It was just craziness all to happen while I'm so jet lagged.
Yeah, good now!
I took care of it.
So I don't have to think about it for the next couple of
months.
But...
even the dead have to do taxes yeah it's actually that's why
don't become a ghost just just do not pass go wait do wait
uh just go do not stop in between don't become a ghost you
have to pay taxes I am telling you to resolve everything in
your current life living and then just Decease don't become
a ghost have no regrets live happy and move on Don't be like
me Don't be like me because you'll have to Keep doing taxes
in the afterlife.
What's the point when will my eternal rescue?
Sorry, okay crashing out just a little bit.
Okay, we're fine though Everything's fun.
Yes.
Damon Seal, thank you so much for the fifth day of gift.
Thank you so much.
The certainties are death, taxes, and cute idol vtubers.
No.
I missed this so much.
What did you miss?
Yeah.
Honestly, I can't keep a coherent thought.
So I'm so sorry.
I tried to take a nap before stream, and I couldn't.
So I'm sorry that I am like this.
I'm sorry that I'm like this.
That's why I'm going to stream.
No, I am streaming.
I'm going to sing.
So that I can stay awake.
and maybe develop my frontal lobe again or something I don't
know I can't even think the idea of having to do my own
taxes scares me thank gosh they're taking care of for me
yeah me too I just collect all the information and then I I
shove them at someone else and I say please help please help
help me it's the tax person was just like, I'm explaining
all this stuff that you probably already know.
I was like, no.
I'm not a business savvy person at all.
I don't know anything.
You guys might be like, oh, Minto's got it all put together.
Actually, you probably don't think that at all.
I don't know anything.
I feel like I was thrown into this.
I just want to stream and be silly goofy.
I didn't know that.
It would come with so many responsibilities.
Sometimes I'm like, man, I really wish that I stayed like...
So small because then I wouldn't have to own a business.
I could...
You know!
Don't be sorry, you're perfect like this.
Rustically, Trace, thank you so much for the pick!
Citric acid is supposed to help with the brain fog.
If you have some lemonade or something...
I have... Wait, Yuzu is citric acid, no?
Literally a girl boss now I'm girl bossing I'm girl bossing
Use it with citrus Citric acid is vitamin C Okay well then I
want to make a I want to make a user T in a bit Almost a
hero, meet the love Thank you!
Oh my gosh, make me Thank you for the ghost, I hope
Definition of suffering from success
If we got married, we could file jointly.
Actually, I did see how much that the married couples get...
They get... They have to pay less.
What the heck?
I'm sorry that I'm not married.
This is so messed up.
We're married still, right, hey?
Oh.
Where's the documents that I can show that to the
government, Orca?
Guys, if one day I said I got married for tax purposes,
would that be okay?
Hello, everybody.
It's...
No, Minky Taxor is...
We can change that, queen.
You should marry all of us for bonus tax return.
If we all got married, then we would all be able to file.
Wait, if you are in the US.
Wait!
Highly illegal.
No, shh.
Shh.
Hey, girl.
What a pay less tax together.
Actually, I just finished my tax job today.
time to join the stream.
Welcome back, Vinky.
Thank you!
Marry a JP Aibu for the passport and the tax incentives.
Why JP?
The green card?
Is that what you're...
It's not tax fraud.
It's tax fun!
Marry Snake like the guy who married Miku.
I have many...
So all of my little...
little men that i that i smuggled in i didn't actually do
that i bought them well i did kind of smuggle them in my
suitcase all my little rexes and my rays and my snakes there
are so my the way my chair is is it has like a little
platform because i kind of sit like a gremlin with like my
feet up and stuff and so they're all currently right there
so they're all at my feet right now You adopted them.
Yes, yes, I adopted them.
With money.
Children also give tax breaks.
What about my cat?
I have two furry children.
You've got enough on your plate without trying to put
together an Ibu tax haven.
I don't understand this.
Can you illustrate it?
I could take a picture.
They're all just kind of in a pile right now.
hold on let me take a picture i'll keep my toe in there so
you guys can see
i'm wearing socks don't worry
they're just all at my feet and i keep stepping on them
but i can't believe i only got one box snake it's kind of
crazy
second let me get the picture
you'll see my sock it's kind of an old sock sorry if it
looks funny it's pink oh
so there's just my pile of guys i was just like i was just
looking at them and admiring them and i just decided i
didn't want to part with them so i kept them close to me
There's just a little pile of...
It's just a pile of guys.
It's a war zone?
Get that foot away from the boy pile.
Yeah.
They're all just there.
They're all just hanging out.
It's so funny because I love to put little snake next to big
boss and they like he's actually littler than big boss so it
looks like father and son and it's so stinking cute like i
love to just and then i like to put him in his arms like a
baby little snake his arms like a baby and then i try to
it's just i've just been fidgeting with them.
Katamari looking pile.
Never speak to me or am I unfontorable again.
So true.
Bent Phantom and the 400k Ibu's I really, really love her
for tax reasons anime.
A manga adaptation coming soon.
What is that?
What was that?
The 100 girlfriends anime?
Box Snake in a compromised position.
help that man.
No, I wanted him like that.
Honestly, the dumpy on this little guy is insane.
I love putting him ass up because he's like in fetal
position.
So he really gets into like a... Anyway, okay.
I'm gonna sing.
I'm gonna sing today.
Did you know there are cheaper ways to acquire figurines and
to fly to and from Japan for a week anyway?
Welcome back.
We missed you.
You know, actually, what I paid for this is cheaper than if
I were to get them online.
Just saying.
And I could quit at any time.
I could quit at any time.
This is a singing stream.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I am going to sing whatever I feel like singing because...
As I just want to say.
sing baby baby baby baby my baby I kept saying that on my
trip when I would see Koharu I would be like baby my baby
baby did you know Koharu's birthday is tomorrow baby my
little baby her birthday is tomorrow baby my baby and then I
would skip I would get anything from the gotcha and I would
go baby my baby little Baby Rex, my baby.
Baby, my baby.
Oh, no, Chad, she still is on down.
She forgot we were in the middle of the third song.
No.
Let's, let's, let's,
let's, let's sing a song.
Sing.
Sing a song.
Meow, meow, meow.
Forever me.
No!
Forever, meow.
I want to be forever, meow.
Do you really want to meow forever and ever and ever?
Are we still doing forever meow?
Can't tell if you sent that before I started singing her
after.
Minto needs S.A.
Snake Anonymous.
No!
I'm okay!
I can quit any time!
birth of us and we don't for you miss but happy happy puppy
and we don't have a wonderful break thank you thank you
thank you i love that there are certain words phrases that
activate the brain rod it's if isn't brain rod if it's my
own thing i came up with forever meow that's my thing
forever meow let's do forever meow
I sent it before, I swear to God, we love forever, meow
forever.
It is.
Wait, what's the original, hmm?
Oh, I found it.
I think so.
How does that song go?
Let's dance in style.
Let's dance for a while.
We're only watching disguise hoping for the best but
expecting the worst Are you gonna drop the I thought that
said brain rot.
Let us do Live forever.
We don't have the power, but we never sit never Sitting in a
sandpit life is a short trip the music's for the sad cat Can
you imagine when the race is won?
Turn our golden faces into the sun Praising our leaders were
getting into The music's played by the mad bed forever Meow
I want to be forever, meow Do you really want to meow
forever?
Forever And ever Forever Forever
I don't know this song.
How did I sing it before?
It's hard to get old without a cause.
I don't want to perish like a fading horse.
Yield is like diamonds in the sun.
And diamonds are forever.
So many adventures couldn't happen today.
forgot to play So many wishes are swinging out of the blue
We let them come true Forever meow I want to be Forever meow
Do you really want to meow Forever Forever Forever Forever
meow I want to be Forever meow Do you really want to meow
forever, forever, and ever, forever, meow?
I want to be forever, meow.
Do you really want to meow forever?
Oops, I forgot again that it gets all dramatic at the end.
Yeah, MIDI holes.
Okay, that was just a warm-up, everybody.
That was just a warm-up.
I do have some actual songs that I want to sing.
Actually, there was one song that I mentioned on a karaoke
not too long ago, I feel like.
And then KaraFund added it.
So I'm like, yippee!
I've never sung it before.
Let's just try it.
Big stretch.
Daigo!
Oh my goodness.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I'm at the gym, can we get some inspirational music?
Yeah, yeah, maybe this one is inspirational.
Maybe.
Excited for Oh shit, I'll blink.
Yeah!
Me too!
Okay.
I'm gonna try singing this one.
But I'm gonna try, I'm gonna try for real.
I hope I, I hope I don't mess it up.
If I do, whatever.
When I see the devil's eyes, I'll look away and smile wide,
you found me.
Then I'll know you're also there, cause proof is in the
adversary.
You found me.
A drag path etched in the surface as evidence I left there.
It's too low!
A sad sack laying on the surface Can you find me?
When I see the devil's eyes A current travels down my spine
You found me A drag path etched in the surface As evidence,
I left there on purpose A sad sack laying on the surface Can
you find me?
I dug my heels into the gravel As evidence for you to
unravel A drag path edged in the surface Can you find me?
Can you, can you, can you, can you A drag path edged in the
surface As evidence I left there on purpose A sad sack
laying on the surface Can you find me?
I dug my heels into the gravel As evidence for you to
unravel A jackpot etched in the surface Can you find me?
Can you find me?
I feel like it didn't...
The original is so much better.
It didn't have like the...
The oof, the...
You know, like sometimes the karaoke's versions are really
good on this app, but sometimes they like...
Missed the mark a little bit.
I don't know.
It was okay.
Yay!
It was good!
Thank you!
It was my first time singing it, so I felt nervous about it.
Yay!
Yay, yay!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
We were blessed.
No.
Let's try.
Wait.
You guys know, um...
Oh wait, do I know the song?
I only heard like snippets of it from...
From...
Project Hail Mary!
Welcome back, Minto.
I miss your lovely voice.
Thank you, Rikadan!
Thank you.
Wait.
Can I try?
Wait, hold on.
Let me hear a little really quick.
I think maybe I can do it.
No.
I could try.
Just stop your crying.
It's a sign of the times.
Welcome to the final show.
Hope you're wearing your hat.
best clothes you can't bribe the door on your way to the sky
you look pretty good down here but you ain't really good we
never learn we've been here before why are we always stuck
from running from the bullets
We never learn we've been here before Why aren't we always
looking running from the bullets
Just stop your crying, it's a sign of the times We gotta get
away from here We gotta get away from here Just stop your
crying, it'll be hard They told me that the end is near We
gotta pick it away from here Just stop your crying, have the
time of your life The atmosphere And things are pretty good
from here
Everything will be alright We can meet again somewhere
Somewhere far away from here We never learn we've been here
before Why are we always stuck and running from the bullets?
We never learn we've been here before Why are we always
stuck and running from the bullets?
Just stop your crying, it's a sign of the times We gotta get
away from here We gotta get away from here Stop your crying,
baby, it'll be alright They told me that the end is near We
gotta get away from here We never learn we've been here
before Why are we always stuck and running from the bullets?
The bullets
We never learn we've been here before Why are we always
stuck and running from the bullets?
The
bullets I don't remember this part.
Oh no!
Wait, Halal.
I don't know this part at all.
Oopsie!
Here, I'll sing with Harry Styles for a little bit.
We'll level the line.
We've been here before.
It's just what we know.
No, no.
No.
Stop crying, baby, it's a sign of the times We gotta get
away from you We gotta get away We got to get away We gotta
get away We gotta get away
We got to, we got to run We got to, we got to run We got to,
we got to run Run away
Yay!
It's so funny because so much of the song is the same and
then I just want to Then I'm like, oh wait, I don't know, I
don't know the rest of the song
Sign of the times.
I'll learn the rest, and I'll do it properly next time.
Thank you!
We've got to save the sun, Minky.
Rocky Grace, save humanity.
Can't stay long.
Heading to a concert.
Have fun!
Have fun, nerdy.
Thank you so much, Minky.
Amaze, amaze, amaze!
Thank you!
Jade!
if you guys haven't seen Project Hail Mary it's just so good
I love that movie I'm so glad because the first time I saw
it well I say the first time the only time I saw it was was
was um oh and IMAX that's what I wanted to say and it was
made for IMAX so I still need to see it oh it's so good it's
so good It's just so...
Wee!
It makes me go wee!
Makes me go wee!
Nah.
I went to see it in theaters, it was great.
Honestly, I'm like...
I'm like, you know...
I'm not the...
I'm not like a... Like I like movies, but I'm not someone
that's like a...
like a... an elitist about it.
And I'm not like, oh, you need to see this movie in
theaters.
Like, you know, if you want to wait for it to come out,
streaming or whatever that i you know usually it's like cool
but that movie project till mary i think i think in theaters
is really worth for real because it's just that good it's
just so oh project till mary is saving cinema right it feels
like it it was a theater movie it was it was oh i could gush
about it all day To be honest, it's just so good.
It's so good.
I think they're doing 70mm screening soon.
I want to see it again.
I do.
Now I kind of want to sing a Beatles song.
Tangentially religion.
What Beatles song should I sing?
I'm trying to think of the ones that I know well enough.
The yellow submarine.
I used to, actually, when I was a kid, I watched that movie
like a million times.
Please gush about it more.
I love Project Hilarity too.
Oh my gosh, let's!
Thank you so much.
Got my headphones in at work doing overtime.
Oh, overtime!
No!
Hope I didn't miss much.
Welcome back, Vito.
Thank you.
Good luck with the world.
Good luck with good luck with work.
Oh my goodness
Wait, hold on I'm gonna see if I can remember this one
because this one
Hold on Okay, I'll try it this song I've actually I Have
listened to Liz's version of this song so much so I'll try
it myself obviously I won't sound nearly as good as her but
that's I actually heard I've heard her version more than the
more than than the original hazzah
black ah who are you so Sorry.
Scary man.
Blackbird singing in the dead of night, take these broken
wings and learn to fly.
All your life, we're only waiting for this moment to arise.
Blackbird singing in the dead of night.
these sunken eyes and learn to see all your life.
You were only waiting for this moment to be free.
Blackbird fly.
What's the key here?
Maybe karaoke today was a mistake.
I was right.
Bird fly
the light of a dark black night.
My brain is all scrambled.
It's actually pretty crazy key changes in the song.
That's a bird.
Oh my god, there's birds.
Black birds sing in the dead of night.
Take the...
Are you, all your life, you were only waiting for this
moment.
What the hell is this bird sound?
The bird is the keychain.
It sounds, it sounds so robotic.
What is this?
Why does it sound like that?
Wait, hold on.
on i gotta hear that again
it's called blackbird yeah my bad okay i'm gonna sing a song
i can actually oh then wait
let's let's get let's in let's let's get let's let's I have
no idea.
I hired R2D2 for the bird noises.
Minto, I'm sick and I get a feel better beam!
Of course!
Feel better!
Be...
Was
that...
Did that work?
Keep going!
Ring.
Minto, Minto peev!
That was a powerful one.
It's because I was sick!
I know how it feels.
I was sick once.
The Minto alarm.
Hello, Minto.
Hello!
Hello, hello.
Can I sing some levi?
I'm gonna sing live very...
These songs I know, probably.
Probably, probably, probably, probably.
Yes?
Okay.
Sorry, they're not the most like up and up, jump up and get
excited songs.
But I like these songs, so...
Maybe they won't make me fall asleep, I hope.
Oh, no!
No, no, we're fine.
Probably.
Let's try this one.
I don't think I've ever sung this one before.
I will sing.
Fragile by Lover.
In case you want to look it up.
closer to you I know that you're older but what can I do I
leave in the morning I'll forget that I am surely fully I
grew up in a case of fragile glass But hammer away, it's
time to crash And as it shatters, let me shatter into you
The soft candle glow, the music so slow, your skin on my
skin, the room is big.
In and nerve in my bone I'm shaking, oh no I'm talking
though I shouldn't be I've lost all sensibility Ooh
I've never been so fragile I got a red?
Thank you!
Sorry I don't say who Ooh
It's been a year and 40 days Since you picked me up And
swept me away I wanted to run with you Into the midnight Sun
with you Now I sit around and rust in rain turn into dust as
I just wait for someone to hold me like you did that night I
still remember the soft candle glow the music so slow your
skin on my skin the room kept spinning round i'm alone new
town on my own i'm missing you i shouldn't be i've lost all
sensibility oh i've never been so fragile
Yeah.
Wait a second.
Someone said, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um,
um, who, where I did it?
I will sing an idol song.
I was thinking of this song earlier, actually.
I was just like, oh, I love this song so much.
Well, Donito, thank you.
He's like, lay my song.
So basically, thank you.
That one I never sung before.
But it's kind of been stuck in my head recently.
So I wanted to try it.
Not my favorite of hers, but I do like it a lot.
Thank you for the gift that Alex.
Thank you.
And also, Tiz himself, thank you.
and Phil, thank you.
Ahab, thank you.
Nah, well, thank you.
Rusty glitch face.
Thank you, Dorgo.
Thank you.
I hope I didn't miss on you.
Superliminal, thank you.
Thank you for the beam, though.
You have cured many hours.
I hope I cure you too.
Oh, go-gag.
Oh, go-gag-gag.
Oh, go-gag-gag-gag.
Yay.
Let's see.
Okay.
I'm going to try singing this AKB song then.
Wait, let me make sure this is a...
actual karaoke.
Okay, wait, let me get the lyrics too.
This doesn't have any.
Did you guys... Okay, for those who know calls, you know,
kind of nowadays, people go, Ja, or Ja, Ikuzo, Ja, Ikuzo,
but...
Way back in my day, we started...
We started calls with Yo shai kuzo!
That's how we started mix.
I think this is the full version.
This song is all about, it's called Shonichi, and it's about
like an idol.
Shonichi, it means like like the opening day, like the first
day.
So it's like okay boomer.
So it's about like uh idol's first day like on stage
basically and kind of just like their dreams that they have
and you know sometimes days are hard but but there's a part
where it's just like we'll sing until we're dead and we'll
dance until we're dead and we'll give it all we've got and
stuff like that so it's a very like uh for a lot of idols
it's you know it's kind of like a Very, like, way, song for
them, you know what I mean?
Hopeful song, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, boom, it gives a lot of, you know, I often see, like,
other idols talking about it as, like, oh, the song gave me
so much, so much encouragement.
Milm, man, I love Minky.
Milm, wait.
Man, I love eating Mike Tyson's ass.
Wait, I don't think I should say that.
But it's your name.
Wait, I didn't think about
it.
I'm going to shake the song now.
Oh.
Sorry, I just realized you couldn't hear it.
That'd be cool.
Yo-cha, let's go!
Tiger!
Fire!
I'm...
I'm standing.
I'm a big fan of the stage.
I'm a big fan.
Haku-shu-tone-gay-tone-gay-tone-none-none-none-none-none-none-none-none-none-none.
And today, the chance of the mark will open.
One only, yes, yes, yes.
On the way, yes, yes.
On the way back, there are.
I'm not going to sing, but I'm not confident.
I'm going to lose my heart.
I'm going to see my rival The stars are bright and bright.
The dream is a sweat in the rain.
It's a little bit, it's a flower.
The dream is never a lie.
The dream is a sweat in the rain and I'm waiting for you.
I'm always waiting for you If it's gonna be my wish to make
a dream come true.
It's so bright and bright.
It's a long night, it's like the day of the day.
Baa, baa, baa, baa.
I don't want to lose anyone.
I'm sure it's our show and it's a gata, gata.
I'm gonna get it.
Why do you think you're so good?
I'm so happy and I cried on the day There are school and
lessons in the world, I'm sorry I didn't give up But the
encore I heard somewhere somewhere The dream was the one of
the tears at the moment The crying and the smiling flower
The flower
Yay!
Wait, now I kind of want to sing more, it could be...
It could be 48.
Wait, River!
Oh my gosh, wait, can I sing River?
Why am I asking?
Okay, this song is so good, but I recommend listening to the
original because it's just...
It's so good.
It's such a good song.
How's my favorite ghost doing this fine evening?
I always love hearing you sing.
Thank you, Maddie!
I'm great.
I think I've sung this song before.
in karaoke I can't remember though I'll sing it again though
wait
48 why is this
let me see if I can find a version that doesn't have the
melody it's kind of annoying it's kind of a meadow nash blog
has been removed okay sorry we're gonna have to deal with
this terrible wait i think i can find a better let me find
one what about this one let me double check it
this one's even worse listen to this
okay wait i'm gonna try it maybe if i sing with it it sound
better That sounds like Donkey Kong.
Let's try it, let's try it.
A-K-B-O, just kidding.
It sounds so terrible.
Diver, Diver, Diver, Diver.
Diver, Diver.
Diver
Believe yourself!
Mastle, Succeme!
Your face will be dark,
ha, ha, ha!
It's so bad.
I'm sorry, I can't.
One second.
Let me try another one.
It's so like, it's so polite.
This song is not polite.
You know what I mean?
Hold on, let me try and find another one.
It's such a good song, though.
When they made the karaoke, I'm not sure they realized
people by trying to sing to it.
It's so funny.
Oh, gosh.
I think this one will get me copyright struggle.
Why is it so hard to find a good version of the song?
Hmm.
Okay, one last one.
I'll try.
No.
I can't use it.
I can't use...
They're just like here.
Here's the...
Here's the original instrumental.
I can't use that.
All right.
We'll just go back to the original one that I was using.
Sorry.
I can't.
It's so bad.
River, river, is this supposed to be the harmony?
River, river, river, river Tamasareru, river Mayoying wants
to do not Conjure on me, so yeah Tamarayuna, now Just go
one, step one, Step one, believe yourself Ha ha
ha ha Maasuk, susume Kao, wotare, ha
It's always a dream that's far too far away It's hard to
reach you to feel like you're on the ground One of your
feet, one of your feet And I'm gonna give you time to look
When you see me in the face In the face, the river is
flowing A big, big and big face The sky's dark, or the flow
is fast, or the sea's fast.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no longer.
No, more, just believe me.
In the dark, in the dark, Just a little bit more.
Fully.
Handle.
There's no way.
No, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no.
The hole in the ice is a dream.
You can't even hear the sound that can't hear any sound from
your heart.
The river is flowing through the It's a very hard, a hard,
but even if it's not good, even if it's hard, even if it's
too long to get to where it's hard to go.
Just keep going, keep giving up, and give it up.
There's a place where there's that there's always to get to
the place where it's Get over it!
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
It's called no, no, no.
Ah, using the words to diminish, Watch where the fireんですs.
a very big, big, big, big world.
It's a deep, deep, deep, and it can be fast, I believe
you are more, with me.
Believe me, believe me.
No, in your heart, there's no blood that's flowing
My song is so hard to sing one person.
Yari, now say, now say, now say, now say, Yari,
now say, now say, yi, yi, yi, You can't do it!
Sounds like something Den Setsu should cover.
I honestly had that same exact thought while I was singing
it.
I was like, man, I kind of want to sing this with the
girlies.
It is not a song for one person to sing.
I learned that just now.
It's such a good song, though.
You guys should listen to the original.
I promise.
It's much better than what I just did.
It's such a good song.
It's like basically a song that's like, don't give up.
You know, you can get through the river and stuff, you know.
Heavy rotation next.
Heavy rotation.
What's another AKB song?
I feel like I sing heavy rotation often.
Wait, this one's a medley.
it's 14 minutes long I wonder how many of these I know hit
medley oh I don't know the first one wait wait wait wait
wait I
don't remember the how this song goes wait let's just skip
it to the next song I don't remember it at all wait no I
give up anyway next song it's a medley we could just skip
the first song I know
Why do you spell medley?
Oh my gosh, it's been like 10 years since I heard the song.
Safe.
I'm more nouguant The spring of the spring Flickr'nagare
Watch the day Aterrasy Atele Pah, Pah, Pah, Pah, Pah Tomo,
oh Ohmoyde, Ohmoydey, It's a bright Ares Ohm, ohm, ohm Ohm,
ohm, oh I'm not the door to the door, but the door to the
door.
My friends, we're all on each way, we're going to go.
Sayonara, don't say it again.
I'm still going to see you.
So now we're high touchy-touchy-touchy-touchy.
🎵 🎵 🎵 🎵
🎵 🎵 🎵
🎵 🎵 🎵 🎵 🎵 🎵 🎵
SPEAKER ¶¶ ¶¶ Flandgate, I'm one instrument.
¶¶ proposed right by the hand you got round some flusket?
≤ What are you saying?
Before you go, in your thoughts, who can hear me, ¶ me, oh
my God, oh God, who is going on?
What's in the past?
Because flaringket, ≤ ¶¶ ¶ Oh my
god, the kingdom check
Sorry, I'm like dancing along with all of these I was such a
sticking I was crazy for it could be so long ago And so I
remember like the dances sometimes a little bit
I love you, I love you.
I'm just trying to get you.
I'm on my way to walk.
I'm on my bike, walking along the way.
I'm just so madly, I'm so excited.
On the ocean, on the beach, on the west side, I'm just
enjoying the sun.
GINCAN CHECK GINCAN CHECK You're coming HANCZO DESHAT
SHATMANNASHU DAD ETOCIC ETOCIC UTS NACCAT The COKORO COSI
CORNA DANCAN GINCANCANCACK GINCK Coying Moyo Blue White Blue
This song, the music video is kind of cursed because first
the girls die in it but also there's a ghost in it.
Where the flowers are, The flowering flowering Hilarly, With
the wind, The wind is going to When everybody flattacks The
time comes to come And I'm alone, I'm going to walk out And
I'm going to walk With you and I met I loved the seasons The
seasons of the season
Oh my gosh, and this song, beginner, in your position, set!
The music video, the original one, got taken down from
YouTube for being too gory.
The girls were dying in it.
You can't find it on the official channel anymore.
I'll explain everything after I'll explain everything after
you, without the hope of the moment.
Now, we're all dreaming about it.
A child like a kid, a child, a child, a child.
A child, a child, a child, a child.
Change your mind.
What's a new, new beginner?
Cha, cha, cha, cha, cha, cha, cha.
I like it, it's like I can't always die.
It's a very kind of Sizzling of a Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm around you, I'm all day long.
It's like a lot of cute little Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I didn't know how to tune and move my fingers.
I'm moving out.
I'm not able to stop my own feelings.
Come on, come on, come on, come on, baby.
I'm gonna tell you, I'm a love-tune-cool-key-oh.
I want
you, I need you, I need you, I love
music, I love music, music, heavy rotation,
And we're surprised And we run over here Da-da-da-da-da
Pop-a-da-da-da-da Ha-jik-e-kernu-y Suki-to-you
Moshi-kern-dolling Odoro-dolling
I want you I want you I need you, I need you I love you, I
love you Give me an
impact to high tension I want you, I need you I love you
Heart
rotation Heavy rotation Oh my gosh, that was 14 straight
minutes of singing.
Holy cow.
Oh my god.
Okay, I'll go back.
Okay, I'm going to give you guys a brief A-K-B lesson.
All right, just some stuff.
So one of the songs,
The...
Okay, so the music video...
starts with like two of the members meeting up 10 years
later that's the song is called 10-year sakura basically and
uh they meet up and they are reminiscing over 10 years ago
and stuff and the music video shows these girls on a bus and
they're like each and like they're having their partying
they're having a good time they're like wee wee you know not
the french and then later it shows them in the classroom and
they have like a road map on like a desk right and they they
show the girls taking the bus like a toy bus and like
running it off the side of the road and it's kind of like
that's strange and then the girls start getting off the bus
until there's one girl left right and like one of the other
girls is like crying as she's as the bus is leaving kind of
implying that like an accident happened and maybe it's
really it's a subtle it's a subtle kind of detail that you
see in the music video right that's like really interesting
but also if you look up june and zakura and like ghost i
guess i guess i guess you would let me see if if you look up
yuray let's see june zakura i can actually maybe see if i
can find the Let's see if I can find the, uh, the ghost
picture.
Kauai!
Yune!
It's one of the things that, that, that pops up.
It pops up.
Look at this.
This is so freaky.
It's so scary.
Because the, the music video is already kind of like spooky,
right?
But then in the window of the school.
Do you see it?
Spooky!
here wait wait wait i could show you the roadmap too wait is
it
spooky spooky um and there's like some other like freaky
stories that happen with this with this song in this music
video in particular so hold on let me show you a little bit
so you have like good visual like a um because i probably
explained it really poorly so here's like oh my gosh what is
this old like youtube like yeah this is from like this like
a scary like an old blog explaining why it was kind of
creepy um but like they're this is the map that like i was
talking about on the desk and then they like take the bus
and they just like run it off the the road of it it's kind
of weird and then at one point too like you know the girls
are out having fun they're partying one second they were
having fun and all partying and then why are they so sad why
are they all so sad now it's such a it's such the music
video has more depth than it like you know which i really
like i really appreciate it especially for such a fun and
happy sounding song but when akb used to have soul i don't
know i don't keep up with them anymore i don't know what
they're doing but um the sad the song right after that was
beginner which was uh uh no sorry that's river i'm an idiot
wait uh okay so the music video you can probably find the
actual music video you uploaded somewhere but um basically
if you try to find the full music video on the akb channel
you won't you won't be able to because people like
complained um that it was so dark basically the girls are
like hooked up to it the the idols they're hooked up to like
a video game simulation and they're fighting against like
these shapes it sounds really stupid but the shapes are
literally Like girls are getting decapitated and like
smashed to death.
And like, um, it's all, it's, it's kind of, it's like
actually like kind of like, ooh, some of it make me go like,
ooh, if you die in that game, you die in real life.
Well, actually one of the members, she starts realizing that
she is in a game and the shape turns into a triangle and
stabs her hand.
And she disconnects from the game.
And like her screams are visceral.
Like, let me see if I could just play that part.
It's kind of insane.
Wait.
Oh, I found a music video.
Okay, good.
Someone did re-upload it.
Let's see if I can.
Let me, I can show you probably the music video without like
playing the song, you know, like you could just see some of
the deaths.
I'm like, dang, this is like, this goes crazy.
It goes, it goes actually like pretty crazy.
Hold on one second.
I won't play the song itself because I don't want to get in
trouble.
I'll only play snippets of the video.
Let's see.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, good.
I turned it off.
Okay, good.
Let's see.
Oh, wait.
It is off.
Okay, good.
Nami-Rade!
Hello!
Sorry, I'm giving everybody a little AKB-48 history lesson.
Because I just sang some AKB songs.
Thank you for the randomness.
How was the origami killer?
Wait, you are finding out who the origami killer is.
Oh my gosh, I have to watch you play Heavy Ran.
Hi, napplings.
June and Sakura, there's a seven-minute video from the
official channel from 15 years ago.
Or was it longer?
No, that's the one.
That's the one.
Yeah, yeah.
Thank you guys for the gift and thank you.
Oh, she finished it!
Oh my gosh, that game actually changed the way that I say
origami.
I can't say it normally anymore.
I have to say origami.
That game actually changed how I say the thing.
But yeah, this is a music video that was taken down from AKB
because it was deemed too violent.
Let's see how Oshima, let's see how she died.
Oh, this one's pretty bad.
This one's pretty crazy.
Koji Haru!
Oh my god.
It's actually kind of insane.
It's, let's see.
Flinch is what gets me every time here.
Like, it's crazy.
Blah.
Oh my god.
I take it back.
But then Achan wakes up.
See, she got, she got, she's screaming here.
I think, hold on, let me hear where, uh, there should be a
part with, oh, okay, she's still screaming here.
Yeah, she's screaming.
Here, I'll hear you guys.
I'll let you guys hear the screams of her pain.
Music video.
Sorry for that little tangent.
Isn't it so good, though?
So awesome.
So deep, yeah.
I was, it was, so deep when I was when I you know it's so
deep when you're 10 years old and you're like
they went so hard that's a little akb history for you guys
that was actually hardcore I liked it yeah right I was like
dang idols can be so cool
even a girly girly group like akv you know could they had
their moments where there was like where it was like whoa
there these girls are going in thanks for the lesson of
course what should we sing nimmy raid what should we sing
hmm uh some a vampire song
vampire song
Loveful Trampoline I don't know well enough
Plastic love We could do plastic love I like that song Don't
let me tell you something like that Hot and hot in the right
givers Don't let me get you out of love It's a good fight
It's all about you.
Time left me in the dark.
Don't worry Don't worry Love Love On the day From the day
The day and the night The night The night The night On a
yari No disco
I'm sorry I'm sorry I love you.
I love you.
me I I I I'm
I'm I'm always It's a very unique thing, I'm always looking
at him.
For some reason, it's a lot of memories.
It's all going to be together.
The glass will fall and suddenly make me cry.
But the reason for me isn't the same.
The day-to-day of the coldsok and naburi-natured The
hallowed-night-dark The hallowed-night-dark
Ayeshick-gallay-ac-tory The cold-darker The
cold-darker-darker
I'm just playing games, I know that's plastic love Dance to
the plastic beat, another morning comes
the plastic beat, another morning comes I'm just playing
games, I know that's plastic love
Then like the hard cut of the song Yay, plastic love That's
what it's now.
Thank you for the thank you to Taku and five leaf clover.
Welcome to Mimbu Shabutaku.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
City pop.
Yeah, it is a classic.
Classic song.
Plastic love.
Ride on time.
Do I remember?
Hold on, let me listen.
I remember the chorus, you know.
This is me practicing, by the way.
🎵 🎵 🎵 🎵 🎵 🎵 🎵 🎵 🎵 🎵 🎵
🎵 🎵 🎵
I love you.
Everything to love you I love you.
And what do you say?
Now I'm going to tell you I'm going to go.
I'm going to find my own was right on time time love
love whoa
whoa light on time I just ended up starting to sing it
Oh, so, oh, right on time Tokyo, let's see it
Oh, oh, oh, right on time Oh, right on time,
I don't remember this
part, I'm
gonna take you
I need it to practice.
Wait, hold on.
I want to hear that part though.
Wait a second.
No stinking way
I think I can't listen to this Wait that feels wrong No way
It's on here I'm using caravan you guys
Wait but community one that's why i thought it was an
official that's crazy i thought it was an official like
carafone karaoke but it's a sometimes people can upload like
community songs as well i'm not wait that's crazy though i
never thought that it would be on there yeah it's kaitlyn's
version
kaitlyn mayors wait though i was gonna listen to that one
one part Hold on.
I want to hear what the Japanese...
Wow, it actually sounds so good.
Oh, it sounds so good, actually.
Whoever they got for the voice.
Wait, hold on.
Let me hear this part.
I wouldn't have gotten those at all.
Thank you so much for the time, Goethe!
Thank you!
I don't think he's riding on time.
Wow!
Thank you so much for the time, Goethe.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
There was a song I wanted to sing.
I can't remember.
I should have written it down.
Oh, wow, wow.
Maybe it's in my history.
Wait.
Doesn't seem like a...
Have you listened to the new Bruno at all?
I haven't.
What's the new Bruno?
Zuzi Tako, welcome back!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Let's do some like...
Let's say top top top 90s.
Where we got here?
They're my wonder wall.
Let's see.
Britney Spears.
This one, this one's a classic.
I know people like this one.
I've sung this one many of times, but I know people like it.
So I'll sing it again.
Kiss me out of the
bearded barley.
Nightly beside the green, green grass.
Swing, swing.
Swing the spinning step You wear those shoes and I will wear
that dress Oh, kiss me Beneath the milky twilight Lead me
Out on the moonlit And strike up the band and make the
fireflies dance Silver moon sparkling So kiss me
Kiss me, down by the broken treehouse Swing me, up on its
hanging tire Bring, bring, bring your flowered hat We'll
take the trail marked on your father's map Oh, kiss me,
beneath the milky twilight Lead me, out on the moonlit floor
Lift your open hand, strike up the band and make the
fireflies dance, silver moon sparkling.
So kiss me.
Kiss me beneath the milky twilight, lead me out on the
moonlit floor.
Lift your open hand, strike up the band and make the
fireflies dance, silverflies dance.
moon sparkling So kiss me So
kiss me
So kiss me
Yay Also zippering congrats on finishing your taxes.
I read though your Super Chat as So I'm going to sing Le Mez
now.
My favorite song ever, oh, thank you, Vicky.
Kiss me, brings back so many more memories.
Isn't it such a fuzzy song?
Such a fuzzy, funny, not funny, fuzzy feeling song.
It makes me feel like I'm outside in my backyard with my
toes out in the grass in between my toes.
Yeah, it's a fuzzy song.
Rambles.
Ripped to me.
What do you mean, rip?
Join Ahead.
Thank you so much, Pritha.
Take, why, why, why, why?
Why, why, why?
Wait, okay, let's see.
Should we do?
Okay, since we did a kissy song, we'll do a sad, sad all by
myself song now.
What's the, I'm just gonna pick this one.
On my own.
Pretending he's beside me.
All alone, I walk with him till morning.
Why is it so low?
Without him, I feel his arms around me.
And when I lose my way, I close my eyes.
And he has found me.
In the rain, the pavement shines like silver.
All the lights are misty in the river.
In the darkness, the trees are full of starlight.
And all I see is him and me forever and forever.
And I know it's only in my mind that I'm talking to myself
and not to him.
And although I know that he is blind, still I say there's a
way for us I love him but when the night is over he is gone
the rivers just a river without him the world around me
changes the trees are bare and everywhere the streets are
full of strangers I love him But every day I'm learning All
my life I've only been pretending Without me His world will
go on turning A world that's full of happiness That I have
never known
I love him I
love him
I love him But only on my own
I'm over it Sorry I couldn't hit some of the notes there My
bad
Oopsie That was amazing No I think it It was okay Here's a
tube, here's a tube, woo!
Thank you!
Actually, I have no water left, so let me get that so I can
sing more.
More songs.
I'll be right back.
I'll be right here.
I'll put on...
Okay, I'll be fast.
Yeah.
Look, yay!
Yay!
But now I kind of want to sing some musicals.
With the musicals, shall we sing?
SIPA, SIPA, SIPA, SIPA, hold on.
Oh my gosh, I listened to Epic the Musical recently.
I've liked it a lot.
I don't, I can't sing any of the songs.
Unfortunately, I only listened to it.
I didn't, you know.
I haven't gotten to be around much, but I still love and
keep ashes!
high.
Is apple juice?
No, it's just water.
Yeah, one day I'll try and do an epic the musical.
I just know the one part, the I will fall in love with you
over and over again.
I don't know how I will.
Because that was like a trending part of the song.
You're mine.
No, tell me that you're not the same
I only know that part like that I can remember off the top
of my head
but I thought the music I don't I it was so good I actually
am not finished with it I fell asleep so I have to finish
the I have to finish it I just um welcome back wiki thank
you extremely Nishin definitely not expecting, but you know,
Minasoko Nenemude from Blue Summarine Number 6.
I don't, but I will save it so I can listen to it later.
Thank you, Taki!
Taki Matsu, thank you.
Let me save that in my songs to learn.
Bella.
Oh, wait.
Oh my gosh!
I should have sung this song when Nimi rated.
I should have sung the cannibal song.
Barry Bug!
Barry Bug, do you have a request?
Darygo, thanks for that gift.
Wait, who wrote?
Bug raid!
Barry raid!
Oh my god!
Barry, do you have a request?
Barry bug.
Even if I don't know it, I will sing it.
Sure, I'm thinking.
I'm thinking.
Okay.
Bug raid.
Actually, I kind of want to do that as a karaoke stream one
day where you guys give me songs that I don't know and I
just come up with my own versions of the song.
So one day we'll do that.
Can you do cowboy bebop ending?
The real folk blues?
Really?
Okay.
Dang, this is a long ass song.
This song is six and a half minutes.
Why is it so long?
Why
is it so long?
I don't know if I know the full version though.
I don't know.
One of the eyes, one of the four.
One of the eyes of the other.
I'm looking at him.
If you're in your love, you're here to go again and sleep
again.
If you're in the dark, with your eyes on your eyes and eyes
look at someone The Wheel of Volcanoes It's the only way I
know it's true.
It's on the other side.
It's a life that's not bad.
It's just a little bit.
It's the end of the world.
I'm sorry if there's a bridge or something I messed up.
I don't know the full version of the song.
It's just vibes.
How much it can be a chanel, I don't know.
A real focus, a real focus.
A real joy, a joy, a joy, a joy, a joy, a light of
everything No,
no, no,
no.
part of the lyrics
it's hard for me to sing like this though
i gotta go back to that part why was there a beat i gotta
classic lyric beat let me hold on i have to see why i have
to hear with the with the english or not the Sorry, the...
Wow!
When did she say beep?
Did you look at anything?
Thank you so much for the- Thank
you so much for the Hakka Supa.
It's here.
Beep!
Why is so out of place with this song?
So funny.
Sage, thank you so much for the five gifts.
Thank you.
Beep.
Welcome to the arcade.
Let's see.
Hmm.
Do I want to?
No, I don't.
I was going to say, do I want to sing?
Cats, the musical.
I don't think I do.
beep see you space minto thank you minto thank you berry bug
cowboy beep bob am I a robot
hmm wait I want to I want to sing this one I want to sing
this one it's from Chicago the musical wait this song is so
fun I want to try singing it I don't think I've ever sung it
before we've both reached for the got gun got gun oh wait
There we go.
Okay, let me try singing it.
Wait, is this one...
Can I sing this one?
By myself?
Yeah.
Can I?
I'll be Billy.
Maybe.
Mr. Flynn, the reporter...
Let him in, butch.
Oh, that's him.
Okay, Roxy.
Wait, I was gonna be.
You sit on my lap and I'll do all the talking.
Wait, it chose out...
It took the wrong person out.
Wait, huh?
Where'd you come from?
Mississippi.
And your parents.
Wait, okay, hold on.
Okay, sorry.
It's confusing because it's a musical, right?
Okay, hold on.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'll do my best.
Where'd you come from?
Mississippi.
Wait, wait, you guys are my little Roxy, okay?
You guys are my little puppet.
His mouth never moves.
Save our career, we don't...
Okay, I'll try, I'll try.
Mr. Flynn, the reporters are here.
Let them in, Butch.
Okay, Roxy, act like a dummy.
You sit on my lap and I'll do all the talking.
That's me.
Mr. Billy Flynn sings the press conference rags.
Notice how his mouth never moves.
Almost.
From Mississippi And your parents Very wealthy When are they
now?
Six feet under But she was granted one more start The
convent of the sacred heart Shut up!
That's off!
Sorry.
Why is it not turning off?
I agree.
When's your game year?
1920 How old were you?
Don't remember What happened?
Wait, convince me to elope one day.
A convent girl, a runaway marriage.
Oh, it's too terrible, you poor, poor dear.
Who's Red Kate Sleeve?
My ex-boyfriend.
Why did she shoot you?
I was leaving.
Was she angry?
Like a madman.
Still I said, Fred, move along.
She knew that she was doing wrong.
Then describe it.
He came toward me.
With a pistol!
From my bureau!
Did she fight him?
Like a tiger!
He had strength and she had none!
Yeah, we both reached for the gun!
Oh yes, oh yes, oh yes, we both!
Oh yes, we both reached for the gun!
The gun!
For the gun!
Oh yes, oh yes!
They both!
Oh yes, they both reached for the gun!
The gun!
For the gun!
Understandable!
Yes, it's possible!
Perfectly understandable, comprehensible, comprehensible,
Not a bit reprehensible, it's so defensible.
How you feeling?
Very frightened.
Are you sorry?
Are you kidding?
That's my lie too.
What's your statement?
All I'd say is though, though my choo-choo jumped the track,
I'd give my life to bring him back.
Away from jazz and liquor and the men who play for fun
That's the thought that came upon me when we both reached
for the goal Understandable, understandable, yes, it's
perfectly understandable Comprehensible, comprehensible, not
of it reprehensible
I don't know the harmony there.
Oh yes, they both.
Oh yes, they both reached for the gun.
Let me hear it.
That's my lead.
Oh yes, oh yes, oh yes, oh yes.
Oh yes, they both reached for the gun for the gun.
A little louder.
Oh yes, oh yes, oh yes, they both.
Oh yes, they both.
Oh yes, they both reached for the gun, the gun, the gun.
Oh yes, they both reached for the gun for the gun.
Oh yes, oh yes, oh yes, they both, oh yes, they both reach
for the gun, the gun, the gun, the gun, the gun, the gun,
the gun, the gun, the gun, the gun, the gun, the gun, the
gun, the gun, the gun, the gun, the gun, the gun, the gun,
the gun, the gun, the gun, the gun, the gun, the gun, the,
the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the,
the, the, the, the, the,
the, the, the, the, the, the,
the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the,
the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, I'm so angry
You guys just show it up I literally You guys Okay let me
show you Let me show you how Kara fun works Hold on So what
I say Like I turned off his voice I'm not even kidding Like
I'm so angry Hold on Okay Let me Let me show you Alright
I'll get a screenshot real quick Okay, so, so, everything is
color-coded, right?
Let me show you.
Yes, so, yes, so, yes, I feel like I don't even get to sing
any of the song.
Okay, see this?
See, like, how it's, how it's, like, blue, and you have the
orange, which is the, which is the people that are like, oh,
yes, oh, yes, oh, yes, they're both, like, the reporters.
it's all backwards wait maybe and then Billy is green and I
turned him down yeah greed was what I turned it up just so
you could see that Billy is green color but I had him all
the way down I had him all the way down let me see let's see
if I turn some of these other things down let them in butch
maybe wait hold on let me see maybe it's the colors are off
maybe blue is green.
Mr. Flynn, the reporters are here.
When Billy is up, that's when the blues talk.
Okay, hold on.
Let him in.
I figured it out.
Say I'm 11.
He'll do all the talking.
Mr. Billy Flynn sings the press conference rap.
Notice how his mouth never moves.
Almost.
Am I colorblind?
Wait, no, you're not supposed to do that part too.
Very well.
No, shut up.
I give up on this.
song I give up I give up on this song wait though oh my gosh
the song brings back so much memories because I was in like
uh I was in like I did like you know when I did uh musical
training quote unquote they had me sing this song and so I'm
like I'm so like oh It's so nostalgic for me.
But kid, you're working with a star.
The biggest.
Give them the old razzle dazzle, razzle dazzle them.
Give them an act with lots of flash in it and the reaction
will be passionate.
old hocus pocus a beaten feather of
how did that song get into my queue oh you i showed you no i
showed you the qr code don't add songs to my
someone at a song got added to my queue and i was like how
did that happen I was looking around to see if I added it.
But no, it's because of the new arc for the character.
I'll sing the song.
You put it in.
You did this.
Whoever added this to the set.
It wasn't me.
I literally got Rickrolled.
strangers to love you know the rules and so do I have full
commitments what I'm thinking of you want to get this from
any other guy I just want to tell you how I'm feeling gotta
make you understand we're gonna let you down and desert you
I'm never gonna say goodbye.
Never gonna tell a lie.
And hurt you.
We've known each other for so long.
Your heart's been aching, but you're too shy to say it.
Inside we both know what's been going on.
We know the game and we're gonna play it.
And if you ask me how I'm feeling, Don't tell me you're too
blind to see.
Never gonna give you up.
Never gonna let you down.
Never gonna run around and desert you.
Never gonna...
Don't cry.
Never gonna say goodbye.
Never gonna tell a lie and hurt you.
I couldn't find a picture of him.
I'm sure...
Frogger's quite shy, so...
Couldn't find a proper picture of him and found the closest
thing.
Never gonna make you cry.
Never gonna say goodbye.
Never gonna tell a lie and hurt you.
Give you up.
Never gonna give, never gonna give.
We've known each other for so long.
Your heart's been aching.
but you're too shy to say it.
Inside we both know what's been going on.
We know the game and we're gonna play it.
I just wanna tell you how I'm feeling.
Gotta make you understand.
Never gonna give you up, never gonna let you down, never
gonna run around and deserve you.
I'm thinking of pie now.
Kind of want something sweet like a pie.
Because of the dessert.
But what if I want to be deserted?
What if I want someone to take me out for ice cream?
That sounds like a good time.
Dessert, you.
Yeah, I'm thinking that's a good time right now.
Don't say goodbye.
And take me out for some ice cream.
I'll get the fancy stuff.
Like a truffle.
Like something with a...
And something with a gold flakes.
I am a fancy frog after all.
I deserve probably like a...
What's something really expensive?
Fly minion ice cream.
With a gold truffle.
And a green card.
Yep.
someone out there offering never gonna give you up that's my
motto too in fact actually Rick Astley he kind of stole that
from me I saw him back at the at the club back in 62 and I
said hey buddy I'm never gonna give up on you I'm gonna I
was I was that guy was hurling into the toilet and I said
I'm never going to give you up and I'm never going to say
goodbye.
I'm going to help you with this tough time and after this I
think he misunderstood my words because I said I will desert
you meaning I'll take you out for something nice like a
dessert because he wasn't feeling so hot but he kind of
misconstrued my words and now I think I feel like a bad guy.
He was born in 66 Who was I talking to?
Well, thanks for the stream, everybody.
I hope you had a good time.
This is me.
Signing off.
And all the jazz, as they say, on this place,
I think...
Outsu.
Now, how about we change it?
I think it needs a little touch up.
I think that one's kind of old.
Frogbert!
Frogbert you later!
Frog...
Ah!
Froggy out!
I gotta hop on out of here!
My hands are so slimy.
Okay, I got it.